hello good evening we begin tonight with
the breaking news that prince harry
and megan have announced the birth of
their baby daughter her name
is lilibet diana and she was born on
friday morning
at 11 40 in santa barbara california the
couple's second child is named after her
great-grandmother the queen
and her late grandmother the princess of
wales let's speak to skye's royal
correspondent
rhiannon mills so brilliant news
for harry and megan a baby girl with a
nod to both the queen and diana in her
name
that's right and of course this
announcement about a great grandchild
for the queen being announced in a very
different way from how we'd expect
for other great grandchildren announced
from america her first
grandchild great grandchild to be born
outside
of the uk and in a statement harry and
megan
literally in the last few moments have
said it is with great joy that prince
harry and meghan the duke and duchess of
sussex
welcome their daughter lilybet lilly
diana mountbatten windsor
to the world it goes on to say that lily
was born on friday june the 4th at 11 40
am
in the trusted care of the doctors and
staff at santa barbara cottage
hospital in santa barbara california it
says
she weighed seven pounds 11 ounces both
mother and child
are healthy and settling in at home it
then goes on to explain sort of
the names of the child saying that lilly
is the name of her great grandmother her
majesty the queen
whose na family nickname is lillabet it
also says her middle name
diana was chosen to honor her beloved
late grandmother the prince of princess
of wales
at the duke and duchess thank you for
their war for your warm wishes
and prayers as they enjoy this special
time
as a family now we knew that they were
expecting a daughter
because of course they announced it
during that interview with
oprah back in march but of course this
completes their family
now adding a daughter to their son
archie
who celebrated his second birthday in
may but of course it has been
a difficult time for the duke and
duchess of sussex a huge amount of
attention
on them but i think what's interesting
is if we see there that actually the
child was born
on friday and they've decided to take a
little bit of time before announcing to
the world that they have a new child
in their life and i think again it's a
sign of how they want to to do things
differently of course we know that they
moved away from the uk they didn't want
to be settled into that royal life
anymore they wanted to embark on this
new financially independent way of life
and i think again this is them showing
how they want to do things but yeah
wonderful news for the couple they now
have
a daughter uh in their life and also i
think again
really interesting to show so much
discussion recently
about the difficulties between the
sussexes and the rest of the royal
family
um but a really lovely nod that name
lily after her majesty the queen
but also of course we've been talking a
great deal recently
about princess diana especially around
discussions about that panorama
interview
and the fact that her middle name the
middle name of that little girl is diana
again
showing how important princess diana was
to
prince harry as he was growing up as a
young child but also
of course lost her at such a young age